PROFESSOR: The topic of
counting, or combinatorics,
is an important one in a number
of different disciplines,
and notably in computer science.
So the origins of the
combinatorics and counting
are a little bit disreputable.
They come, historically, out
of people studying gambling
and trying to calculate odds
and the fraction of times
that various events occur
to know what kind of bets
to make on them.
So a typical kind
of question would
be-- if you know
how poker works,
there are various
classifications
of five-card hands in poker.
And you might ask, what fraction
of all possible five-card poker
hands translate into
being a pair of jacks?
And basically, this fraction
of total poker hands
which fit into the
category "a pair of jacks"
is the probability
of a pair of jacks.
So counting in gambling
is one fundamental place
where it really comes up.
And historically, that's where
a lot of combinatorics begins.
Related to that is
counting in games.
When you're trying to write,
for example, a computer program
to play chess or checkers or
so on, one of the aspects of it
is getting a sense of
how much searching you
have to do in order to look
ahead to find good moves.
And you wind up counting,
from a given chess position,
how many possible
further positions can you
get to a given number of moves.
A puzzle kind of question, in
solving the Rubik's Cube toy,
is how many different
positions are there,
and how many different
positions can you
get to from a given position?
Concretely, in computer science,
it comes up in algorithms.
It's often the case that
an essential question
is, how many
operations does it take
to do a manipulation
on a data structure
and to update it
from one to another?
For example, how
many comparisons
does it take to sort
n numerical items?
And typically, the
count is n log n,
proved as a number of operations
that are both achievable
and a lower bound.
One that we've seen when we
looked at fast exponentiation
is a question like,
if you're trying
to compute the nth
power of a number d,
how many multiplications
does it take?
It's roughly log n by using
the iterated squaring method.
And we want to be able to count
that number of multiplications
that a particular program
uses to compute d to the n
in the smallest number
of multiplications
you can get away with.
And a place where, again,
counting and combinatorics
becomes critical is for security
and the issue of cryptography.
If you're going to have
security from passwords,
there needs to be too
large a space of passwords
for an adversary to search
through exhaustively
and check them likewise.
If you're doing encryption
with some kind of secret key
that enables you
to read messages,
you want to be sure that
the space of possible keys
is also way too large
to search exhaustively
to see what keys work.
So let's talk briefly now
about the very basic counting
methods, and two rules
for counting things--
the most rudimentary of
them, but in fact we'll
get some mileage out of them.
So the first rule is
called the Sum Rule,
and it's completely
straightforward and obvious,
which is that if I have two
sets, A and B, that do not
overlap, then the number
of elements in A union B
is simply the number
of elements in A
plus the number
of elements in B.
And there's no issue proving
that-- it's self-evident--
but let's do an example.
Suppose a class has
43 women and 54 men.
How many people are in it?
43 plus 54 equals 97.
This is implicitly
assuming that there's
no one whose sex is
ambiguous and that there's
no third sex, so that men
and women are disjoint.
The total number of
students is the sum
of the number of men and women.
Another one is there
are 26 lowercase Roman
letters and 26 uppercase
Roman letters and 10 digits.
And so there are 26 plus 26
plus 10 equals 62 characters
in that repertoire of symbols.
The second rule is
called the Product Rule,
and just about as obvious.
Suppose I have four
boys and three girls.
How many boy-girl couples
can I assemble out
of four boys and three girls?
And the answer is, there are
four ways to choose a boy,
and for each of them, there are
three ways to choose a girl.
So there's 4 times 3, or
12, possible boy-girl girl
couples in this setting.
More generally, if I
have a set A of size m
and a set B of size n, then
A cross B-- remember, that's
the set of ordered pairs where
the first element is from A
and the second element is
from B-- the size of A cross B
is-- the vertical
bars, remember,
mean size-- is
equal to m times n.
So let's just do an example
that illustrates it.
Suppose that A is the set
of four elements-- little a,
b, c, and d-- and B is the set
of three numbers, 1, 2, and 3.
Then I can list A cross
B in a nice orderly way,
as a 4-by-3 matrix.
But this is really meant to
be just a list of elements,
but I'm organizing this way so
the pattern is more apparent.
And for each element
little a, I can pair it
with each of the
three elements in B.
And for the second
element, little b, in A,
I can pair it with this
three digits [? in A. ?]
And c I can pair with three,
and d I can pair with three.
And that's where the 4 times 3
comes from, and more generally,
the m times n comes from.
A useful immediate
application of this
is, how many binary
strings are there?
How many strings of zeros and
ones are there of length 4?
Well, the length
for binary strings,
it can be explained as well
as the product of B times B
times B times B. We're not
writing parentheses here.
It's B times B-- cross B.
So I'm thinking of a
quadruple like this
as being a pair whose
first element is a triple.
And a triple is a pair whose
first element is a pair.
And given that it doesn't really
matter how you break it up,
we just typically
write it as B cross
B cross B, and even abbreviate
that as B to the fourth,
where b is 0, 1.
And the Product Rule says
that the size of this
is the size of B
times the size of B
times the size of B times the
size of B, or 2 to the fourth.
So in general, if
I look at strings
of length n, whose elements
are from an alphabet of size m,
the total number of such
strings is m to the n.